das konnte ich leider nicht erraten
google
ich hasse dich heißt justin bieber 16
kopien des video auf youtube skype
channel please leute das lied all stars
die kamera läuft schon
auf jeden fall kommen wollte video leute
ich habe heute eine seite entdeckt die
ich bisher noch nicht kannte ich weiß
nicht ob ich hinterm mond leber ob er
schon länger kennt aber jetzt wie
gesehen und ich musste eigentlich feier
die richtig und zwar google kultur ich
habe es probiert feiere ich ultra und
zwar ist prinzip dahinter man ist auf
dieser seite hier da oben steht und was
das ließ man sich nicht durch dann
klickt man auf und los und dann hat man
eine gewisse menge an zeit um dinge zu
zeichnen die einen dieser seite vorgeben
und dann versucht diese seite mit
künstlicher intelligenz zu erkennen was
man gerade mal das heute probiert ich
liebe das alter und ja wir können
zusammen meine zeichen skills engine
wird schon okay leute fangen wir an wir
müssen trauben malen wir haben 90 kurze
zeit vorher gesagt dass das bei mir
hätte schief gehen könnte weil ich doch
eigentlich gar nicht zeichnen kann das
stimmt nicht ich kann tanzen
ich kann singen wieso sollte ich dann
nicht zeichnen können let's go boys
trauben mehrerer ich sehe grün
nein nein schnauze
[Musik]
das konnte ich leider nicht erraten
okay das was wir eine achterbahn
zeichnen in 19 sekunden also erstmal die
ich sie wissen ganz klar hier
naja oder den eiffelturm was nein ich
sehe wippe
ohne die chinesische mauer protest us
dollar 89
das konnte ich leider nicht erraten
alter google hofen 19 sekunden
hier ist es um fenster hier
bilderrahmens aus und den rebellen ein
jetzt weiß ich dass offen gesagt
sporthose war immer noch okay ich über
19 sekunden das schau ich mir auf jeden
fall zu hier ist es hier wende
gröbere jetzt weiß ich es probieren ich
muss zugeben ich war nach den ersten
paar mal ein bisschen niedergeschlagen
aber kein problem und das ist ja das
schöne reißig ist und schraubenzieher
ich singe linie nein oder 3 wurde
hochhaus größer jetzt weiß ich es
schraubenzieher exakt gezeigt also
netzwerk hat viele zeichen erkannt
zeitweilig hatte das etwas andere ist
okay was hat der bei achterbahn erkannt
chinesische mauer gartenschlauch ganz
kurz was zur hölle was hat das mit dem
gartenschlauch zu tun einfach einfach so
war die frage ich sehe in kreuzau eisen
was 300 jahre an den regen gerostet hat
erste runde überstand leute aber jetzt
geht es darum die zweite stelle zu
schaffen wir haben sechs zeichnungen und
müssen alle sechs richtig zeichnung
beraten lassen noch mal spielen
steckdose sah ich sehe ellbogen main
oder quadrat 9 oder waschmaschine
jetzt weiß ich es steckdose okay die
chinesische mauer
jetzt weiß ich es die chinesische mauer
becher 19 sekunden
weil ernst ich sehe bei oder quadrat mal
welcher oder ellenbogen wurde dreieck
nein ich sehe tasse nein oder einmal das
konnte ich leider nicht erraten google
der final four am regenbogen das ist mal
so ganz klar
ich sehe brücke rückenflosse jetzt weiß
ich es delfin keinerlei sowieso eine
banane mit einem auge der rückenflosse
stereoanlage 19 sekunden vielleicht
schaffen wir fünf aus sechs zumindest an
adressbücher jetzt weiß ich es
stereoanlage achteck ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
und 8
jetzt weiß ich es acht er sollte letzter
versuch eine runde flyers 6 von 6 kommt
schon google mit
eine mücke rücken flügel die richtige
lücke
diese stammte ist der staffel stark ich
bin ratlos
das konnte ich leider nicht erraten
google
ich hasse dich die leute das war es nur
ein kleiner ausflug in die welt von
google doch ich muss sagen er hat so
einen webseiten spielt noch nie wirklich
nie so spaß gemacht voll geil was uns im
team online findet ihr hier drüben jetzt
noch einer folge was das geht da habe
ich zusammen mit ella eine runde ich
habe noch nie auf dem wasser speed kanal
gespielt die folgejahre ab und lassen
aber auf dem mast es geht kann da würde
mich freuen und macht's gut